series a more perfect union aims to show
that what unites us is stronger than
what divides us today we look at an
effort to help the homeless on any given
night an estimated five hundred and
forty-four thousand Americans experience
homelessness and in 2016 more than 15
million US households were food insecure
meaning they lacked consistent access to
food Ladd Amir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is here with the story of
one man who is helping feed the needy
one weekend at a time
Vlad good morning good morning al-amin
Mohammad knows firsthand the pain of
homelessness and hunger and he also
knows how much a little can help every
weekend in Syracuse New York its
sandwich Saturday starting at 10 a.m.
granola bars chips and sandwiches here's
the bread assembled in lunch kits ready
to go to those who need them most
there's thousands thousands of people it
has hopeless right now in these streets
dozens of volunteers mobilize every
Saturday to help Syracuse is cold and
hungry behind the leadership of Al Amin
Muhammad but we're here for one purpose
one purpose is the happy humanity right
that's what we're here for right you
guys they come to eat my food up did you
the volunteers head out and set up under
a bridge but during this particularly
cold winter it's not just food they're
giving away jackets and hygiene kits are
also handed out but it's more than the
food and clothing that the needy of
Syracuse get every Saturday they get
human connection bonds that are
difficult to form on the street you're a
weak one I don't have too much money
come down here and get a meal some hot
cocoa and all the people coming together
and we talk and we network so everybody
can help each other out and the
volunteers have found a deeper
connection too it means everything to me
it's so positive I get a chance to help
people I get a chance to meet new people
sandwich Saturdays is part of the
nonprofit we rise above the streets the
name describes Al Amin Muhammad's life
when I was in the streets
really hopeless it was a lot of people
Walker passed me I was invisible his
path to homelessness began early when he
joined a gang as a teenager in his
hometown of Chicago Cubs died selling
drugs started getting into violence I
got shot several times like twice in a
different occasion after multiple
arrests Mohammad ended up in prison
there he says he found God and converted
to Islam Mohammed knew when he got out
he couldn't go back to his former life
just like the homeless Mohamed now helps
he found someone to turn to a caseworker
in a detox center he told me all to mean
I believe in you and I believe that you
don't get off this condition you can
help a lot of people in his world that
belief was enough Mohamed got back on
his feet and became a drug counselor he
got married and lives in Syracuse with
his wife nasira
we use trail mix bars and together
they're working to help the people in
Syracuse every Saturday
you'll find them under the bridge giving
clothing hope and a sandwich we'll
continue to do this work and I'm gonna
continue to fight and I'm gonna continue
to say couple of people out here cuz I'm
somebody trust means my believing me and
they say to me everything that goes into
those lunch kit is a gotten through
donations and what really struck me
about this story guys is not only did he
hit rock bottom
Mohamed he almost thought about
committing suicide so he found
redemption through this but that
families are getting involved so in
other words if a mother decides to join
sandwich Saturdays then her kids join in
and now you have a whole families that
are taking part in this you know what I
like to the importance that all you need
is one person to believe in you that
caseworker who said I believe in you I
know that you're better than this
imagine the message that sent to him and
what he's now sending to others I
learned this from working with meals for
wheels here in in New York it's not it's
not just about the food it's important
it's about the connection he says people
want to know that somebody else cares
about you and wants to try and help you
not to be a nameless faceless person you
just pass on the street yeah humanity
matters thank you glad